[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faire
c'est le vélo vert
ce soir
la fin
là
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
là
ça
on voulait démarrer l'année en 10 ans
cette année ça va être n'importe quoi la
cei
d'attention
[Applaudissements]
oh
écoutez chier un peu de la vie de
géraldine j'ai croisé un mec aussi
incroyable qu'elle une institution il ya
une minute on était tous dans l'âge en
train de jeter on n'a pas vu leur
arrivée il ya franchement on était en
train de boire tempêté la nouvelle année
voilà trois qu'il avait que du champomy
on va pas se mentir
merci j'avoue bien de mettre mon
oreiller me dis aussi personne ne pas
s'en fait plus à ajaccio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]